getting played for a chump by Donald
Trump that is the subject of tonight's
waters words after little Rocketman
badmouth Mike Pence and failed to prep
for the Singapore summit Trump did what
John Kerry should have done he walked
away from the table based on the recent
statement of North Korea I have decided
to terminate the plan summit in
Singapore on June 12th well many things
can happen and a great opportunity lies
ahead potentially I believe that this is
a tremendous setback for North Korea and
indeed a setback for the world if and
when Kim jong-un's uses to engage in
constructive dialogue and actions I am
waiting POTUS also sent the North Korean
a leader letter which read in part you
talk about your nuclear capabilities but
ours are so massive and powerful that I
pray to God they will never have to be
used I felt a wonderful dialogue was
building up between you and me and
ultimately it is only that dialogue that
matters someday I look very much forward
to meeting you in the meantime I want to
thank you for the release of those
hostages who are now home with their
families that was a beautiful gesture
and was very much appreciated if you
change your mind having to do with this
most important summit please do not
hesitate to call me or write incredible
letter and classic art of the deal
Trump never locked in we'll see what
happens if the meeting happens it
happens and if it doesn't we go on to
the next step we're moving along and
we'll see what happens there are certain
conditions that we want and I think
we'll get those conditions and if we
don't we don't have the meeting well
we're gonna see what happens on
Singapore we're gonna see we're gonna
say so the president gave up nothing
while the North Koreans destroyed their
nuclear testing facility froze ballistic
missile tests committed to end the
Korean War and released American
hostages Trump pulls out on principle
and Kim gets put in his place and loses
face now America is negotiating from an
even stronger position believe it to the
left all they see is a
for Kim I think it's a good thing for
kim jeong-hoon when he got this letter
from the president saying okay nevermind
he must be having a giggle fit the art
of the Paloma Sea is a lot harder than
the art of the deal the president that
was rehearsing his endzone dance and we
weren't even at the 50-yard line yet on
this summit it goes that Nobel Peace
Prize he was so let me get this straight
when Trump announced the summit the dem
said Kim had won and when Trump canceled
the summit the Dems said Kim had won
it's a perfect example of the left's
duplicity left-wing narrative on North
Korea has always favored the North
Koreans at the expense of Trump fire and
fury was too tough our allies weren't
behind us China wouldn't help us
remember the media gets suckered into
North Korean Olympic propaganda and they
said Kim jong-un's sister was a better
diplomat than Ivanka Democrats I with
America's opponents just to score
political points against Trump for
example in the course of this presidency
Democrats have defended Hamas ms-13
Iranian mullahs waterboarded terrorists
risky Syrian refugees and anti feh Trump
success as box Democrats into such
radical positions they're becoming
politically irrational and now the North
Koreans signaling they want the meeting
back on president Trump's reaction let
me see what happens we're talking to
them now it was a very nice statement
they put out we'll see what happens
we'll see what happens it could even be
the 12th we're talking to them now they
very much want to do it we'd like to do
it we're gonna see what happens
clearly the North Koreans want this more
than the United States Trump has the
upper hand and the Democrats have no
hand